previously on Peugeot stuck Bob once I
reach my apex kill you're gonna see oh
well with my skill reaches a fact you
mock me you mock me no I no mock you now
you make fun of wait I speed you cruel
cruel man oh I'll never get back up oh
my god if I could stop hitting every
single [ __ ] time I get some momentum
I lose it
oh my god I swear oh my god I swear
oh hey Mart wait don't talk to me are
you talking to because you're you're not
you're not supposed to talk to me don't
talk to my god every time every time
every time every [ __ ] time ever I
swear to God every [ __ ] time so good
right now can you get your stupid heart
explosion out of here it's blocking my
field of view oh where is my problem
coming about this where's my problem
coming from then your attitude my dude
okay all right cool and what's causing
me to be in a sour attitude huh you're
lucky
somebody's outlook on life is a little
and the down in the dumps you know my
god
oh I swear I will fly to San Francisco
oh you sure we can hang out get some
kombucha with Mark actually might come
kill me I wish I could say that I'm
doing a bit right now I wish people
don't understand why I don't play rains
games anymore they're always like oh I
can't see because of all the [ __ ]
effects of where I am oh my god oh my
god why are you here
yes yes leave I think so
oh wait I think you broke mark me I
think it was more like we facing
I mean hey man mark if you can hear us I
think this is a great idea
he's just putting his headphones back on
yeah yeah hi hi hey how's it going you
know you sound triggered I am fine you
know it's okay not to be okay sometimes
I'm fine are you sure yeah are you
feeling the Pogo love yet mark hang on
hang on
there we go okay now hey guys how you
doing
good to see you how you been good old
KITT how you been how you been guys easy
easy with that now I got it it's all
good just just do it watch out for the
win there bud
well it's all good Oh careful good dude
it's me we're talking about here
I'm not smug here you are the guy who's
always careful you never lose your cool
wait I'm not sorry
Oh Mike what good I swing what Bob are
you seeing this
oh my god
Oh feels so good oh no oh it's okay it's
okay everyone why are you to me so
you're so close mark you got this I got
there you go
there you go they go they go they go
okay just need Opower on that one yeah
yeah yeah no no my god oh my god
no mark you're so close dude oh you can
Pogo off the ceiling did you know that I
know yeah oh my god oh my god
[Laughter]
okay that makes no sense
oh that makes no sense I was perfect
are you why do you laugh at me you're
just a stupid looking I think it's funny
this this kind of is a multiplayer game
but it really doesn't feel multiplayer
you know oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god they did that's good
don't talk to me how many times have I
said you don't talk to me I'm back at
the bottom of the hill that's great wait
hey wait how's the weather okay
no left oh the one time the one time I
let go of the space button is the one
time I hope you feel bad way [ __ ] hey
that's it : hey bomb
wait so still windy so windy up here yes
it is
hey Mark how's going no no no into the
balls the balls alright we're back in
the hole mark do you like the hole the
up here I don't know if now's a good
time to talk to him I could I could hurt
you I can't I have the ability would you
have to gain from it nothing but please
in silence you know I would haunt your
ass if I could I let me come friends
with the spirit that haunts my house and
I would I'd come back yes yes oh hi
pausing so I can't bounce out oh I'm
taking a bite I'm sorry
[Laughter]
never leave this room I mean I mean you
don't know it's bad
there I made it what is this wait what
is this bar what the hell is this bar
bar I got like an energy bar I don't
know what you're talking about
there's a yellow bar by my experience
dad no not the bottom at next to my
character there's a yellow bar that
happens when you build beer booths yeah
but it wasn't there before
maybe you're just finally a good what
level are you I don't know eight I'm
nine so maybe that's a certain that's
like a level based on lock what are we
doing here it's Bob do you really like
this game it's fun man oh come on it's a
little terrifyingly high stakes but it's
really fun years I don't think it's fun
yes so fun yeah fun fun is the word oh
my god I swear counts is what are you
guys up the little thing way if the wall
jump back and forth yet yeah I think you
have 200 to the left jump up on that
hill left yes and then you got climb a
tree
dude when you hit level 10 your jumps
become a little bigger you get some
thicker Jim I made it where am I going
oh you have to know god of course you do
of course you do [ __ ] of course okay
I'm safe again Jesus Christ oh my god
seriously this is dopey men oh [ __ ]
christ everything you say is meant to in
fury
you are trying you were trying Bob don't
mean damn dude
yeah well Oh nuts
I mustn't it up now stop stop I wasn't
saying positive mind you I'm not talking
to you I'm not talking to you you have
been talking to me I'm not now oh [ __ ]
off I can't tell I can't tell it could
be dark could not be directed to me
big [ __ ] mystery over here stop
touching the bottom of the bottom button
that's disappointing I want to thank her
how's your progress coming along more
that's not gonna help you no it would
not encouragement doesn't help
admonishment doesn't help only silence
the serenity of the sea the deepness on
the gates on everybody's murder you in
your sleep you'd have to come back to
Cincinnati for that oh my god Oh Mike
you be good it's not funny if you did it
I'm just that's what I hey how's it
going man
you got this you got this you good I'm
having a lot of issues climbing this so
uh mark how's it hanging
how's the pogo right yeah you're doing
good man I feel like you're really
picking it up okay I'm good hey guys how
you doing hey good to see you how you
been
hey wait how's it going I deserve this
you do you deserve I'm glad you
recognized that I know I do but like
it's still oh no don't don't call my new
is fine it was fine work no god I mean
it's not funny not that that I was
loving it trust me it's not honey that's
really mean and mean-spirited and not
nice and I would never do that to you
your good friend mark I told you how
good of a friend you are recently
yeah yeah you did yeah nice birthday
tweet that was herb text very nice thank
you I I meant all that I'm sure you did
a period it's unrelated to this okay I
understand we're having an experience
here that might make you feel like all
the nice things I said were in some way
instance see well that happened how does
this even happen hey you know what it
happens to everyone
look look look where I ended up right
next to you I don't I just can't no no
no no no not you not you now you're it's
fine it's fine I'm better what I was
saying is like I just I I've I've
started to learn I've only learned how
to never let go of this and I I'm to the
point where I recognize I would be less
frustrated if I did let go but I
physically cannot let go of it now that
I've mm calmly go oh my god this wind is
killer man
so you would I tell you
oh my god I swear I I swear Oh Oh my
[ __ ] up hey man welcome back to this
part of hell you're back with your
friends my dude would you guys believe
me if I said I was over the tree no I
was I was over the tree I was over the
tree and I didn't realize what you had
to do when you got over the tree so I
just jumped down into that pit below the
tree and then I fell all the way back
and I've never been able to get back
since
what's your max percentage mark 20.3 am
I'm nineteen point five oh you do passed
me at my highest is 20 point zero
yeah I know mmm I was beyond the tree oh
come on
I just want to do it I just want to do a
boost that the wind on that island goes
the other way
why has no one told me it oh my god I've
been compensating the wrong way on that
island this whole [ __ ] time Oh God
just [ __ ] take me down anything you
want just stop yes yes yes I'm in the
hole just I mean the hole yes I'm in the
hole I'm in the hole oh I'm in the hole
hey what's up wait I'm in the hallway oh
we're in the hole together come here let
me hold you this is the best hole I this
this jump here is this
Dibley hard yeah I know but like at
least its see [ __ ] I'm up above the hole
don't worry about me I'm making good
progress
I just got upset a little bit okay mark
I just calm down with the shooting
yourself off the wall situation my dude
I just oh my god what's with the [ __ ]
music to play it for you music oh banjo
I'm sorry please scream more about how
it's more like banjos it's fine
oh my god oh my god oh my god alright
I'll take this [ __ ] [ __ ] the baby what
are you talking about the baby what baby
the the tear face baby what you've not
seen to your face babe what are you
talking about it pops up next to my head
and laughs at me way it's got a drug
problem
what no God [ __ ] oh my god oh my god
how far to go
[Music]